i'm putting it on autopilot and
disconnecting
okay
is everything all right you seem quiet
bob and teddy are dead and it's my fault
teddy and bob they knew the races
so do i if you know how this would turn
out
i'd do it all over again for anyone in
the clan
saul told me you brought in some help
from akoshi
someone from the outside
old and who is that
alton ai roguish you're getting help
from an ai
well nothing can surprise me now only
one capable of breaking into arasaka's
systems
and we wouldn't get into mikoshi without
her
well we sure as hell wouldn't get out
you trust her this halt
yeah she'll help us
why something got you worried
i trust you that's all i'll say
by extension i trust the salt won't pull
any rugs out from under us
things will work out they gotta
come too far for him not too
this would be it
how much farther to our soccer tower
not far it should be moving from here
[ __ ] do you see them
come on b we have a to-do list
you should be used to this by now saul
things rarely go as planned
fellas what's the issue carol and the
rest
militech's all riled up cut them off
they won't last long on that site
jesus christ i'm taking the panzer they
need all the help they can get
are you out of your mind the answer is
no
you can't operate the panzer alone
without frying that gunk brain of yours
do you have a better idea
they're family pan i'm not leaving them
behind
saul are you on board with this v
someone make him see reason
mitch is right the three of us have
still got a decent shot
but without him they've got none you're
sure about this
saul we're talking goddamn suicide
look out for yourselves they'll kill you
i'll catch you later
carol i'm heading your way hang in there
you'll owe me a beer after this
they're gonna we can't but all this be
for nothing
you two go on up and see what's gotten
into it once your mobile i'll follow
secure the rear fee let's go
mitch i'm here
be careful please i can handle myself
pan
likewise for you get some akoshi in one
piece
all right here we go pitch out please no
more car cups please
[Music]
[Music]
check in and start her up it looks like
the engine overheated and choked when
drill bit met reinforced concrete
moment of truth here it goes
[Music]
don't worry
take it
talk to me no no no no no pan am
i'm here i'm a bit bruised
i haven't do it worse damn for sick i
thought you'd
that's okay v everything's okay that's
all
[Music]
the tunnel's clear for now still nothing
i knew it
could be a problem with the comms
come on let's finish this
[Music]
they will regret this
we have some kind of maintenance shaft
it looks like it leads upwards
i'm gonna puke we stopped to think it's
incredible we happened to be standing
right with the age q bomb left a huge
crater
then isn't this place positively
saturated with radiation
who knows great
he's having another seizure baby are you
okay
hey
[Music]
the guards need our attention first
[Music]
don't like this not one bite
no unwanted attention
[Music]
a note what now old chard
you need to pour the jacket into give me
one more second
i found it it's not far you can jack in
your personal there
i'm sending you the shortest route we
need to lift this goddamn lockdown first
christmas
go all go
damn it that's it
we've got heavy casualty
right now
taking heavy losses
hmm
uh
nice work
okay i'm here alt
the shard's in yes how much
time do you need to it is done
oh yes it worked
keep going
[Music]
coach
oh
come on man let's end this
it's the hush
uh
they didn't have to die
no mercy it seems gotta remember what
mercy is
to show any
this is it we made it
a few steps is all that separates you
from mikoshi
it seems you'll finally get your chance
that will be at the core
you can do this
[ __ ] oh
[Music]
stupid
[Music]
there will be nothing left
come here
you spread
you are not
is
their defenses are breached
to the corner lies open but we don't
[Music]
adam smasher i remember you
promised to kill silverhand once
i'm gonna let you in on a little secret
johnny
he's here with us now he can't talk
but i can feel him under my skin
what the [ __ ] are you talking about in
the end
got you silver hand triumphs
[Music]
pan am i'm going to miss that constant
bickering
the unending fight i never knew when
oxmoor stubborn
and follow family into fire
and in the end did exactly that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you don't look too strong i'll make it
lean on me
i can do this
[Music]
so listen all i know for sure is alts
bound to stage a coo in my head can't
know who'll be coming back from this
cyber jaunt
so i gotta thank you now v shut up and
do whatever you have to do
any partying advice just be yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
i know
jackie gonna be up to our next
juicy contracts bro there i can feel it
where are we it's a dream
be all right v you'll see
our soccer do this hit you with soul
killer
how's that even possible you died
misty dude misty always knows
jackie amigo
you really got no idea who i am
jackie gonna be up to our next
juicy contracts bro there i can feel
it where are we
it's a dream it'll be all right v
you'll see
goodbye old friend
afterlife see you there
let us go then you and i
when the evening is spread out against
the sky
like a patient etherized upon a table
let us go through certain half-deserted
streets
the muttering retreats of restless
nights and one-night cheap hotels
and sawdust restaurants and oyster
shells
streets that follow like a tedious
argument
of insidious intent to lead you to an
overwhelming question
oh do not ask what is it
let us go and make our visit
[Laughter]
so
so
it worked i'm gonna [ __ ] live
gotta admit you cobbled together a good
plan
been my curse in my nightmare johnny but
i do owe you one thing
day to day with silverham by my side i
learned to kick down barriers
now nothing can hold me back i can feel
it
is that so meaning you've made a
decision about us
want a word with alt first where's the
winch
have haven't caught on yet have you what
what do you mean alts already split us
once you jacked into makoshi she lit you
up with soul killer
your output don't [ __ ] around i am not
his girlfriend
[Music]
hey alt so seeing as we seem to have the
soul splitting out of the way
what's next i am currently verifying the
checksum
and eliminating engram copy errors in
the process
wait you mean i am i a construct
she means you followed in my footsteps
next steps to copy you into the gog's
brain
you two still plan to obliterate mikoshi
it's gotta burn what about everyone
locked away there
i will free them take them with me
cut the crap you gobble them up like so
many morsels of code
make a part of you as if they could hope
for anything
better come on
so that's really it we're done
you kept your word there is one aspect i
failed
to take into account old what
the body is a key factor in this
transaction
dna reconfiguration by the relic has
progressed
too far added to aggressive invasive
medications
the body's immune system attacking its
own christ will you just skip to the end
after i transfer your construct into
your body
you will die it is inevitable it is
imminent
no no way that was not our deal
you shall live for about six months
perhaps somewhat more
no no no there's got to be something
something we haven't thought of your
body will see you as an intruder
but it's my body the biochip's nanites
have altered it permanently
the body is now johnny oh give us a
minute
he and i need to talk
i thank believe it everything
all we did it was pointless
i've had enough of this of everything
you most of all perfect because we're
sticking to the plan
i'm going with all [ __ ] knows where
you're keeping your body
where's she even gonna take you beyond
the black wall
to become part of her whatever the hell
that means
[Music]
there's really no other way as i said
johnny can retain the body
[Music]
for everyone involved here
for folks like us
[Music]
this bridge leads deeper into cyberspace
cross it and permanently sever the
connection with your body
the path to your body passes through
that mortal well
oh if you were me
what would you do you should come with
me
what's that mean for me exactly am i
gonna
[Music]
become like you i was a netrunner i
understood how to survive i cannot speak
for you
beyond the black wall dangerous lurk
that is no sanctuary
but it's better to be a free spirit
shredded than to wither
trapped in a dying body don't do it v
you've been running from this all along
it'll change you you won't be you
anymore
and you already took that first step a
while back
i'll have an easier go of it
i told you i said i wanted you to have
my body
but but i can't do it
i'm sorry
goodbye
never stop fighting
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
up in smoke with damage valued in excess
of the annual budget of many a small
country
serves you right sucka hustfield be on
your knees huh
worry not on wash masses our wondrous
lives in night city won't change much
but when do they ever we live
with dust and chrome and miss dust and
chrome we shall all die
now for some good news and some bad news
good news is something like a sandstorm
this way comes from the south
why'd you want to meet here for the view
were you turning sentimental on me
so you do remember i thought of it then
as a one-time thing
i would help you you would help
[ __ ] no no that's a lie
mm-hmm add it in for the raffins
you were out to get him with mitch's and
scorpion's help
if they'd agreed you'd have told me to
[ __ ] off then and there
oh stop
look at the city somewhere in there
those
bastards from arasaka are wondering how
they lost everything
they'll figure it out one day but we'll
be long gone
you'll never find us can promise you
that
i know perhaps that's why i need a good
long look
one day this view will be a happy memory
about to turn on your heel never to see
the city again
i think that makes you happy right now
and you ready do you feel the road
beckoning
it's possibly your last glance at those
buildings
it's just not there what i'm looking for
do you think we'll ever find it doubt it
maybe that's not so bad if night city
taught me anything
it's to beware of your dreams cause
somehow they always find a way to come
back and bite you in the ass
v you're bleeding again
don't worry about it i'm fine what's the
plan
everything is set we'll meet our people
soon
gather our gear and set off yes the road
could be hard
but as long as we don't [ __ ] up we
should cross the border in a matter of
hours
let's get out of here sure
but v get a good look at the city
one last time if you need to i mean
i'll wait in the car
well night city good night and good luck
[Music]
confirmed that his sis hanako was among
the victims
so it seems we've got to change your
comment at the tippity top of the
megacorp
soaked in the usual gallons of blood
sweat and tears of course
this is rot i've heard enough
most of our people have already crossed
they'll wait for us on the other side
and our souvenirs from mikoshi if we so
much as approached the gates with tech
like that they would wipe us out without
warning
we've checked arasaka has people at
every border crossing
but we know a road less traveled
just realized here i am clapping from
arasaka again
don't you worry we'll pass right under
the bastard's noses
we better new beginnings can be rough
don't you know it
there is one thing i will miss about
night city what's that
the food the tie on seventh and haywood
the pierogies down by the docks
seriously you'll understand once you've
ridden with us for a while
really then i can't wait of course our
new lives will be nothing but pure
[ __ ] chaos
of that i have no doubt doesn't matter
gonna be a good life i can feel it
and you'll sense it too
are you running from night city or going
to your grannies for cookies and milk
gun it or that storm will catch you
screw you
[ __ ] hey baby good to hear you jim
how's things give me a month and i'll be
as good as new
i told you all i'd be fine didn't i come
on mitch
you weren't nearly that confident after
mikoshi none of us were he was in bed
for weeks
a vegetable it would have been the end
of him if not for his synapses
toughened made almost fryproof in
panzer's back in the war
did save every one of our asses though
petty saul's not with us or teddy
or bobby or scorpion
they would have kicked your ass out of
whack after that move with the panzer
then hugged you until you puked i know
pan am i know
give us all a chance at a new start
let's not [ __ ] it up
i'm glad you're with us v see you soon
i can smell the ozone even through the
air conditioning
it's that storm getting close
okay we've arrived it's high time
hey mitch hey let's get the [ __ ] out of
here
shall we hey how are things is
everything arranged
everything's almost set so you found it
where we thought it would be all plans
laid in in place
they are indeed come see us when you're
done
we'll talk about the who what and how